hello and welcome to gamespot of Thrones
bit different this week guys we're in
lovely San Francisco visiting our US
counterpart how're you finding it it's
lovely it's really nice Sergio is insane
yeah it's incredible I mean if we're
here again we're gonna have to put some
like Game of Thrones yep very slowly
becomes some figures into there I'm nice
James of course joined by tomorrow
saying hello Dave to it either um so
we're gonna be talking about the lace
episode which is season 6 episode 7 the
broken man so if you haven't seen it go
away turn away now because we're gonna
be going in deep because the hype is so
real now right guys is many men I mean
the hyper mobile yeah all confirmed it's
all everything we wanted it to be is
happening Clegane bowl yeah okay let's
start with the recap but I think it's
worth noting that there are a few
different things about this episode so
first of all had a cold open mmm so to
bring the Hound back he's back and a
porta back of the cold open which I
think was very smart because it kind of
lured you into the episode a bit more
than just having the title sequence but
it snaps i'll call the broker man yeah
and i was quite surprised that there was
no brand yeah that's always be assumed
that me rethink broke a man he's the
epitome of broken the paralyzed
waist-down man but there is a kind of a
meaning to the broken man existing in
the books right so book readers were
like this is obviously the Hound episode
because Septon Mara bald who was played
by ian mcshane we knew that he was going
to be the peacenik the Septon the
wandering septum because he said it
broke his NDA quite a while ago in the
book septum herbal gives this incredible
speech and i'll link it below and it's
all about how everyday men who get
conscripted into armies the Westeros
armies kind of get just ground down by
the by being injured by having no food
you know their boots get worn through
because they walk so much of them are so
much and after years of this kind of
life they snap and they desert the army
and form you know just turn to a life of
crime basically don't become highwayman
become robbers so that's where the
broken man basically came from he calls
them broken men hmm but in Game of
Thrones every
yeah so we thought that the broken man
was brand but it could be many people
can beat hound Jamie obviously got one
hand um could also be Theon yeah p on so
what was quite interesting but it's
interesting to see the way that they
went let's just say for this episode the
broken man is the Hound yep so let's
just talk about him clicking bowl hmmm
so saw the episode you get to see him
basically just he's alive seems fine
yeah she's all right yeah I mean
apparently he was broken am a broken man
like he was almost died yeah you know
the septum was like you were mega dead
when I found you and then you just
suddenly came to life which is classic
hound behavior I found you I thought
you've been dead for days what he was
thinking already had bugs all over here
and bomb was coming through it right
there I was gonna give you a proper
burial and then your [ __ ] Oh nearly [ __ ]
myself us in Septon was talking about he
was an ex warrior and he's talking about
the hound and both of them seemed to
have just rejected that life and have
become peaceful man you know I would
chop in sharing food and they have this
kind of conversation where they talk
about their past life and the Septon
does have his own like really good
speech it's not the broken man speech we
talked about his his life and you know
the bad things that he's done yeah it
was basically an opportunity for the
Hound to perhaps to look how he could
change and become a different type of
person and then as the kind of events in
that area transpire doesn't quite go
that way no so the Brotherhood without
banners turn up and they're a little
different too I mean to be honest it
when those guys turned up I thought they
were phrase yeah because one of them had
like to UM you look you look like the
fray yes the twins um but know that the
Brotherhood and they were just basic
like we're gonna take all your stuff and
the Septon just said you know we don't
have anything here's that peace bro
so why what ideas sort of love about
this bit is when the head wounds away
chopping wood again angrily chopping was
really chopping were so angry about he
hears one scream and then he comes
knocking it free for today yeah so sick
whoa did one unified scream um so I'm
going to assume that his the net what's
next for him is some sweet sweet
vengeance yes I'm sword-swinging yeah
but Dave will happen in the north so
starting at the wall we see a tormund
Giantsbane convincing the wildling
cohort to march under Jon Snow they
don't really seem keen but someone has
like an ace in the hole he basically
says he died for us oh I think I'm a
giant was days in the hole well no he
that's that's the eigen he makes he says
John died for us you kind of have to you
know pay him back and if some if a giant
says let's go yeah and kind of followed
him he just stands up and goes nicely
this snow um moving south a little
bronze back probably one of my favorite
actors in Game of Thrones with robson or
was he drew Rome I think he was he's
both of my own yeah um he basically
spends the first few moments dropping
some sass yeah just like machine gun and
I'm just turns up me like phrase your
siege is god-awful yeah start again to I
said yeah pink sake he sees the rubbish
rubbish excuse for a siege he's hanging
out with Jamie and Jamie obviously wants
to go up against the blackfish he's like
he's just an old man braman when we've
only got one hand yeah that's that's why
you're here brother you could be my
other hand straight in with a sick burns
I'm pretty sure bronze only hanging out
until he gets the reward that was
promised him from going to dawn mmm to
be honest if anyone had to go to dawn
and live through that plot line he made
at least half interesting yeah and then
what sounds like the coolest place ever
Bear Island hey on a visitor um John
Sansa dev are still searching for the
men that they need to bolster their army
and after the young ten-year-old ruler
of of Bear Island a small oh my god she
is that's a sassy tenure is leanna
Mormon I love the win the maester leant
over to talk to her she just saw we're
like yeah I
carry over Bear Island but like they
make amazing arguments why they need
this men and then finally she's
persuaded like I and you can have like
60 something 62 what 62 yeah i really
hope i really hope that these 62 men
turn out to be the most badass dudes on
the battlefield and they take like a
hundred Bolton's with them something my
god I think I think you might've screwed
up her times tables she's young yeah
thnkx is like I want to go hundreds and
okay the most is doing ya know city
62,000 he's got an abacus just offshore
night and it's wrong so how's Glover
feels somewhat different moments you
know back then with a 62 eventually
there's only because it Davos but how's
Glover are still feeling the ripples of
Rob screwing up and then Jack Spinelli
yeah well they're not exactly going to
be convinced by San sir john and his
wildlings when Rob had the whole north
and still failed so house clever kind of
just tells them get out of here no man
for you yeah I mean like it's all so you
kind of forget about the like I just how
catastrophic Rob ruins the north and now
that they're meeting all the lesser
houses are like no ho ho do you know
remember what happened last time no man
for you and finally we see the heroic
trio back at their camp doing the maths
and coming to the sad realization they
do not have enough dudes to take on
Winterfell and the Bolton's and I think
sense realizes that but who offered her
more men it's your boy little finger no
I mean there is a great like face that
she pulls her she realizes like she
don't you know so I assume that to her
letter is too yeah and someone has gone
into CSI mode and actually deciphered a
letter zune hands so I think we're gonna
see Knights of the Vale come and save
their sorry waddling butts at this point
so tomorrow what about the South the
South King's Landing we get to see
Marjorie again she's still playing the
pious disciple act she is really giving
the high Sparrow exactly what he wants
to hear so she talks about how when she
was Queen she's to visit the sick and
she kind of felt pity for them but they
also disgusted her so it's like high
sparrows like oh yeah you really have
changed haven't you and so they
discussed that for a bit and then they
talked about for some reason whether
she's boning Tommen properly or not
happy which was real weird also shout
out to Tommen for like talking to the
high Sparrow yeah my wife in the bed so
like she's like nah you know what I kind
of I'm not desires that once drove me on
anymore I'm not feeling it which to be
fair like Commons a ten-year-old not
very experienced she's probably like
ain't nobody got time for Thomas yeah
exactly so then the highest I was like
get the bone in and then let's move on
to your grandma but she's a bit of a
problem so like he's calling her the
unrepentant sinner and basically says
implies that she needs to kind of bring
her grandmother to the light so then we
skip ahead and Marjorie is gone to see
Elena and is like you know hey you
should be real cool God lady with me was
it fun yeah it's great look how awesome
I am I'm like I'm loving it my life is
better than ever and they have a
representative from the faith there as
royalty she's she's a hard [ __ ] yeah
her face is just like suction meant she
doesn't change the sour face looking she
looks like one of the one of the jailers
from Dark Souls 3 yes exactly like one
of those everybody hates as hard as well
she does and then so Marjorie is
disgusting to her and then this is where
her act starts to kind of not slip but
we start to see what she's actually up
to she kind of puts it in her
grandmother's head that maybe she'd be
better off out of King's Landing and
then as she's kind of kneeling down you
can hear that the transfer of a paper
from one hand to the other
and then they leave and then Elena goes
outside and it has a look at the note
and it's just a picture of the house
Tyrell sigil and got it she's an Elena
satisfied that her granddaughter is up
to some tricks and it's like you got
this girl I'm gonna get out of here so
skip ahead a bit and we get the
much-awaited SAS off between Cersei way
it's not one-sided it was just like an
absolute beating it's like Elena just
went in the engine SAS right exactly so
says he comes in and is playing there
she's she's finally figured out her
backs against the wall and like she's
figured out that you know maybe Elena I
need her and Elena knows that says he's
back is against the wall and says listen
our two houses are just in in you know
disrepair and screwed because of you
yeah and she she dunks on you know the
high Sparrow calls him like a sandal
wearing something or another which is I
forgot the exact term but I remember
hearing and going oh savage savage and
then it ends by like again seriously
trying to be like you know we gotta work
together we got this we need to take
care of this together and she's like you
know what you've lost and it's one of
the things that makes me most happy
right now and then says I'm out of here
you should probably do the same and
since I know I'm staying for my son but
Elena's done she says she's all right
because she's got a trial by combat
exactly she has a trial by combat so
she's kind of stuck there and that's the
end of their kind of exchange then we
move over to volantis and Theon is with
his sister Yara and we've taken a break
from running for their lives to like
find a body fine yeah just and it's just
a weird change of pace for them because
they're their uncle is trying to kill
them after you sir ping there they claim
to the throne and like and they're like
yeah let's just hang out and drink for
it a feather uncle has to build a
thousand boats first yeah we can take a
while he is true so the whole point of
this scene is to kind of for you are a
church to really succeed their plan is
to go across the sea and make a pact
with Daenerys but to do that you are any
Greek she needs wreaked go
me and get fee on back now listen to me
I need you the real Theon Greyjoy not
this ratshit pretender can you find him
for me drink your escapes you hear me
you got away and you're never going back
we'll get justice for you if I got
justice my burnt body would hang over
the gates of Winterfell [ __ ] justice
then we'll get revenge drink so like
maybe Theon is over it is remaining
attention but then she's like all right
now many yeah and then she's like now I
got some boobies take care of oh so I
mean like if Theon's like the only one
he's just like SAT there drinking yeah
on his own so in in Braavos hmm we have
aya being a bit weird yeah she's there's
something up with aya she's her
mannerisms were quite different she
shows up and kind of like says I need to
get back to Westeros and the guys that
you ain't got no money for that BAM
sacral appointees to back to silver yeah
and then she's like all right we'll do
it in a couple days I know tomorrow
another sector another one and exactly
and she grabs it again as like i'll see
you at sunrise and then she goes and
stands on a bridge which is very strange
concern obvious yeah because the last
episode it ended with her kind of
holding up getting ready for a fight and
now she's out in the open and then we
have a little old lady coming up behind
grand sweet girl and before she can even
react his gang stabbed by and it is of
course the wave and she jumps off into
the the drink below and wife is like it
she coming up is she coming up she
doesn't she she goes like full
Assassin's Creed yeah like escaping
detection like yeah please confirm that
kill though I think waif is satisfied
that she's done the job and then kind of
walks off and then next thing we see is
Arya walking through the market area
blood dripping almost as if she's
leaving a trail of some sort a very
obvious blood trail and then that's it
done with aya she's a seems to be a bit
off something strange is definitely
afoot
so again I thought this episode had a
lot of setup we I mean the last three
episodes they're also gonna be longer
which I'm really excited about because
they have so much to get through um
there's lots of things that we've been
waiting seasons for ya coming to a head
so i think is a great place to start
with us because i think this is the end
of her Braavos her Braavos story arc i
guess dave you've got some great
theories about this so obviously
mentioned before what happens a higher
was that she was bold as brass going
through the market got stabbed escaped
and kind of don't know what's going to
happen to her now there are a couple of
theories about what when honey because
it felt very unnatural for I a few
people are thinking that it could be
jackin pretending to be aya to test the
wife I like that a lot yeah it's I mean
it you'd have to you'd have to shrink
down right like well no I mean that's
the thing about the the Faceless Men is
that the kind of have that weird ability
yeah cuz are you her face was used on a
dead body before right when she just
before she went blind well the piece of
music plays during the seam is called
Valar morghulis so that's hinting at a
connection to the Faceless Men and we
also know that Jack and may have
something of a soft spot for aya he like
took her in he helped her out killing
Lannisters and took her in when she
finally came over to Braavos and he
tells the wave don't let her suffer now
I'm gonna stab you multiple times and
SWAT make that in that scene she could
have had the perfect opportunity to just
cut her throat you end it but instead I
think he's banking on the fact that the
waif really dislikes her and goes for
the slash and in the stomach and the
place where you want the place you stab
someone if you want to suffer is the
stomach it can take days to bleed out
from a stomach wound or stomach gunshot
as we see in Reservoir Dogs let's get
that reference in there um so it could
be jacking like testing the wave seeing
if the waif is kind of harboring a
grudge which obviously she's not
supposed to exactly but another theory
which I think may hold more water is
that area knew exactly what she was
doing she fully expected to be attacked
by the way yeah her mannerisms are this
scene a much different to how she
normally acts she's very cocky flashing
a cash to draw her attention to herself
she holding needle as well she's going
no she is she's an arm
yeah she is like this though yeah and
and I have a theory as to that stands
yeah I've gone deep here so she's
drawing attention to herself throwing
all this money around people in this
area obviously going to be drawn to you
know cash be a lot of my mouth so I
think that's exactly what she wants she
doesn't she doesn't have to escape this
way she doesn't have to pay a man to
take her away she could she's got the
ninja abilities to sneak on a ship at
night stow away and get away yeah when
the wave approaches wearing the face of
an old woman I was hanging out on the
bridge yeah this location is chosen by
aya in advance because it has an escape
route yeah she could jump off the bridge
and that's her out mm-hmm stabbing like
okay people might say well she got
stabbed I think she knew she was gonna
get stabbed yeah I think she might have
been banking on the wave beam we see her
get stabbed we see a bleed but who's she
recently taken a shine too late male
brain and who would you go to see if you
wanted to act wounded it would not
surprise me if the actors knew how to
fake a wound for their plays maybe it's
like a pig's bladder full of fake blood
and that's what she's using today kind
of disguise and make the ways think
she's wounded so she's blood bloody
stabbed yeah way think she's wounded her
she falls into the water but the waste
got to confirm the kill right yeah
waiting cut leave you can't you can't
you know you got you got the doctors
exactly can't get your contract banked
and the when I escapes from the water
she's leaving a trail of blood and when
we see in the last episode at the end of
it she's got needle she's in a dark area
mhm and she's kind of waiting so I think
I has led a trail to that dark area
where the wave is going to expect a
wounded unarmed i er instead really it's
aya who's armed with needle who no one
else knows about she is completely fine
and she has the training to fight
without his sight she's in Matt Murdock
mode wife is gone get ruined but also
like whenever she's trained with way
it's always been with a staff right yeah
how's the way if ever shown any
proficiency in sword fighting because we
know that I had a trailing with yeah
sort of Braavos
go for us someone also did the the
freeze frames of the old woman's face
yeah and have gone back a little while
and I actually sees the face the way
fuses in the Hall of faces so she would
immediately see this face and be like
I've seen it before anyway real so mean
do you think that I is really in trouble
or is this just her master ninja plan
finally can it definitely feels like
it's a ninja plan because it's just it
it's contrary to everything she's
learned so far it's contrary to the way
she behaves as a character yeah you know
running into a trap that kind of thing
it's it seems too reckless to be aya and
so there's something interesting
happening and I really like the idea of
seeing her kind of combined hurt Syrio
Forel training with her Faceless Men
training using needle because she's but
she's always been using the kind of
stuff is nothing good yeah and she's
been okay I mean she's there were points
where she was taking the wave down and
this is why she was blind so imagine
what she can do when she can see or even
is blinded and has needle which is a
weapon suited to her she's a little more
life she's a little more like balletic
with that stuff she is gonna wreck some
Falls with the soul and it's gonna be
awesome we don't even know if the wave
had the whole blind thing because that
was implied is it was a punishment for I
f er rip like that she took down Meryn
Trant yeah and the PO punishment was to
lose her sight yeah so the wave may
never have had that so she's going in
she's actually going in blind Maya is
completely fine I'm gonna murder her
some waif alright alright let's talk
about some hound we've been big big fans
of the gravedigger theory from the books
and also the quick game ball theory
we've got extended videos on like
exactly breaking those down and what
like all the evidence for and against
but basically gravedigger theory is that
Brienne of Tarth travels took place
called the quiet Isle meets a bunch of
peaceniks basically monks penitent men
and sees a man who could be the Hound
sees the hounds horse and talk to the
guy who says no the Hound is dead the
persona of the Hound is dead Sandor
Clegane is still alive so it's a grave
digger and Clegane bowl is that the
Hound is going to represent the faith
and the mountain will represent the
crown in a battle by comp I by combat
for Cersei Lannister life
so it seems like all these are kind of
like all these pieces are falling into
place this might actually happen this
season finally finally now we've got a
handbag but I think it's quite
interesting that there's some some
slight differences between how it's gone
down in the show compared to how the
events have kind of been seeded in the
book so I thought for example the in
McShane would play the elder brother who
is like this really pious man and leader
of the playa but he didn't he played
septum air-balled who is as he basically
he's a wandering Septon who's been
wandering for about 40 years and he
leads Brienne & Co to the quiet I'll
he's not the leader of it so i thought i
was quite interesting i guess it's just
for ease of tying that they cut the
older brother right and i mean if you
got an actor like ian mcshane you I
capitalize on that yeah I mean one
Episode one death but whatever um also
like the fact the Hound is he's the wood
shop instead of the gravedigger because
that makes more logical sense yeah it's
kind of like it seemed likely it's a
little more lighter like a shows where
he could have gone if he's still if he's
digging graves and come on might make
the audience feel like he's still kind
of a grim dude scoffing would def enough
a gating he needed a task that would
like maintain his strength as well yeah
so like digging graves keep my steps
yeah as if he was just if he's a chef
when he goes up against the mountain
when Clegane ball happens you'd be like
oh I'll chop you've all wasted away I
thought was interesting is the
conversation between Mara bald and the
hound they cut this amazing speech that
was in the book where they talk about
men who abandon armies although I think
that's quite symbolic as well yeah
because we see in the North that John is
completely failing to raise a big army
and the army that he has we saw them
fighting infighting yeah um so that
could be you know those guys aren't
maybe they don't cut it maybe they will
found himself abandoned the Lannisters
yeah exactly but also what we have is
maribel talking about when he was a
warrior and he cut the throat of a young
man a boy while his mother looked on and
was sad and crying says like her screams
horn my dreams which is quite like it is
such strong parallels to Catelyn Stark
who watched his Rob dies and then she
has her own throat cut yeah so I mean
also what I quite liked is that talking
about the suffering of like the men on
the front lines and then you get the
parallels from the Glovers talking and
saying no like we're not joining you
because we've suffered enough we
suffered enough for you is really a
contain dark to kind of re-establish the
hound and kind of because the speech
that septa memorable gives is pretty
much the most heinous thing you can do
in any universe that he's killed a child
in front of the mother and Hound is
probably at that point thinking this
dude's a real bad dude but he's like
he's got the peace thing going on people
like look up to him and he's building
something for the future maybe he's
thinking about what he's done and how he
could potentially do the same thing but
then obviously over the course of you
know the events that happen it's kind of
like actually I think I'm a dude that
likes to kill people because you know
all my would be friends are now dead so
I'm gonna yeah she's just being peaceful
guarantee you it doesn't yeah yeah in
the end in the end the Hound feels like
he was right because you know Mara bald
was trying to present something else and
how did kind of resist it it was always
talking about how you know peace never
worked for him or anything like that and
in the end he's proven correct because
you know all the peaceniks are dead and
he's alive so he's got job to do now
save chopping wood trim yep but also
what's interesting is when marable is
talking about the boys he killed it's
quite interesting that like some people
on line of thinking was he part of the
push to kill all of Rob Robert
Baratheon's bastards which could be an
interesting one I don't know if that's
really confirmed we don't really know
where he's been yeah but also to where
the scene is that the Brotherhood
without banners come and they are really
quite different like I obviously they
they would terrorize like the Lannisters
in the phrase but to attack a peaceful
kind of colony says something I think
about their leadership so if beric
Dondarrion is still in charge I can't
see that but we're going into book
theory territory now which his Lady
Stoneheart so we haven't read the books
probably a good idea to step back now
the Lady Stoneheart as the name that's
been bandied around for the end of this
season the read you know the reanimated
corpse essentially of
it's dark who is full of vengeance and
she takes control of the Brotherhood
without banners and basically just like
they go ham yeah they just start killing
mercilessly wanton killing there is a
couple of connections between the
Brotherhood without banners beric
Dondarrion and what we see there Septon
songs the Hound because the Septon says
to the hand the gods not finished with
you and when the town was their prisoner
yeah beric Dondarrion said the same
things about God kill her the plan for
you or something like that yeah and
obviously the Brotherhood say things
like you know for the night is dark and
full of terrors so maybe like the Lord
of lights magic has brought Catlin back
and that's why they keep saying that and
that's more reinforced i guess but also
catlins calling card is hanging people
so oh well Lady Stoneheart school now
yeah hanging people and so obviously ian
mcshane at the end yep they're hanging
game isn't this the season has been real
good like it hang some good hanging
people ollie excellent proper so where
do we think I mean with all this in mind
I know this season people have been
managing to travel like you know oh you
know they could be right the south of
the country than be up north of the wall
in like a day does he have time to go
deal with the Brotherhood and then still
make it back to King's Landing I mean I
think the time frame is Circe's trial by
combat right like she's hinted that it's
only a few days away but other stuff the
faith is going through it might be
rescheduled like rain check for the air
and the quiet Isle isn't really it's not
exactly it's not not off it's fairly
south ish so in theory this time yeah I
mean by the Lady Stoneheart thing I
think maybe as much as I would love that
are they gonna kind of suffer with
bringing too many people back basically
we know the source of Maya so the guy
that plays him like someone party's
website yes he's definitely confirmed
come back at season six a game of
thrones so we know he's gonna make a
return but like I don't know if it makes
sense to bring Lady Stoneheart back at
this point I think I think she's gonna
be a key plot point of whatever they do
in the future not right now maybe at the
end of the season we see like a picture
of Catalan stars face or something about
the
like the Jon Snow yeah the eyes opening
or something like that or like just her
appearing from the shadows and then
that's what's explored going forward I
think for the Hound to deal with all
that stuff be too much to ask you so
much and like you said like bringing
back multiple characters from from death
in one season might be a bit too much
like people are so kind of dealing with
what the implications of jon snow coming
back means he's changed as a character
to bring that Catlin back and have her
drastically shift in the way she was you
know it would be really difficult to
reconcile all these kind of moving gears
together so I think that the whole Lady
Stoneheart thing needs to be its own
focus later on yeah i think what other
ones is really what you said about jon
was that if he's been brought back to
life he doesn't seem to have that much
of a personality change he's still the
moody kind of I mean the what there was
one episode where he was like oh my
watch is over mmm then like he's not
going around killing everyone happening
innocent whereas it's gonna be difficult
for show viewers to kind of appreciate
that if Lady Stoneheart comes back and
she's a complete vengeful [ __ ] at the
same time I mean cannon stark did see
all her children her pregnant daughter
in law or her loyal men and her family
killed before she then murdered a young
girl yeah so I mean I could appreciate
that John was killed by his friends yeah
but Catlin saw her whole family and
lineage killed and she at that point
what shades were missing yeah yeah yeah
so I mean I can appreciate if callously
like herbs than John it's like a level
of understanding as well to it like
Kathleen her death was unexpected almost
it was a trap whereas Jon Snow I mean he
kind of had the feeling that something
was going on and almost you could
imagine him understanding why he was
killed like you know that was always a
point of you know conflict between
himself and Ollie and the rest of the
you know the the Nights Watch that were
on the other side so when it finally
happened you imagine that he knew why
that happened which kind of grounded him
somewhat so when he came back there
wasn't this like you know ? over what
happened or like this kind of burning
rage to get a vengeance for it at the
moment he came back it was almost like
he understood what happened and he knew
that what was going to happen next
those people were gonna die and he took
care of it so like all that stuff was
resolved straightaway whereas for Catlin
she comes back all her kids are dead
everyone responsible scared so she's got
the reason to be no vengeful well I find
interesting is that I feel like by
bringing so many characters back by
bringing John by bringing the mountain
back by bringing essentially the Hound
back you're kind of lessening the impact
of death in the show yeah because you
know we've had key characters die before
like Ned we've had Joffrey Tywin who
have a rob and they they I guess they
don't have a chance of coming back yeah
where is you know where do you draw the
line yeah I think the main implication
of this though is that it's sowing the
seeds of Clegane bowl and Lady
Stoneheart happening I think it's
they're sewn too late and we're not
gonna get see until next season mmm so
we didn't have any on-screen deaths
really like we know that all the
peaceniks died in McShane got you know
hung 13 oxy the good stuff didn't get to
see the gory good stuff but what we did
have in abundance this week was SAS my
goodness so we've decided to treat to go
for SAS of a week yeah and there has
been so much to choose from Oh time do
you want to start we're gonna go with
liliana he's sassy and sharp and biting
in the way that only a 10 year old can
be you know you know the so is your face
and it hurts when the kid does it that
bad so she she starts off by firstly
dunking on her own mother which is just
savage and she's that know my mom was no
kind of beauty which kind of is like
almost shade to lyanna stark which is
like yeah yeah she was named after you
the beauty leAndria ain't go no time for
no beauties so then from there she goes
to Jon Snow story and Johnstone's I look
I served with such and such such and
she's like shut up ain't got time for
any of this can we cut the crap and get
to the point and John smells like damn
this ten-year-old is on fire so then
from there they kind of present their
their pitches yeah and she's like oh you
know as far as you know your snow and
what the hell i use on SAR us
dog or I you you know one containing
ball or a Lannister like I don't know my
sources are telling me that you're above
everything which is just like
unbelievable I'm like and like sansas
face is like I got take this I can't
even say anything I me I need the men
and then there's like a few minutes of
talking smack from her eventually
they're kind of like okay let's you know
get some men go in this kind of half and
then you know what his face present self
service comes in and saves the day and
she goes alright let's do this ultimate
this is the sassiest moment after
spending what is like 10 minutes just
dunking on these guys she goes all right
i'll give you sixty two men wish what
that is unbelievable they're probably
thinking we took all that [ __ ] for 62
min raveled all this year away took an
emotional battery and you're giving us
from X 10 year old yeah and show my god
that is just I think she's a sassiest
character in Game of Thrones history so
far or is she Dave my son bronze my
favorite for he is a machine gun of
witty SAS ten seconds on screen and he
calls the fray twins and their troops
[ __ ] yep yeah and like like you can dig
a trench any man can dig a trench in
like phrase you can't even bigger trench
properly man it's literally moving dirt
from there to there and sittin in it
Jamie's [ __ ] herb come and about how
he's better instincts than anyone the
Lannister army and he says that's like
saying I have a bigger [ __ ] than anyone
in the unsullied army excellent work
brand and then you like you you're
listening to Jamie because bronze been
promised so much and Jamie says a
Lannister always one just like don't you
say it don't you say it just taken the
wind out of his sails instant later and
say that to Jaime Lannister yeah take
the stones have that relationship um but
wasn't mine my pickers and I mean the
reigning queen of sass if Leanna is the
new bugler yeah Olenna Tyrell my god
like some I mean it's incredible like
Cersei has that smirk and Elenna quite
rightly says like I remember the smirk
when you you have my grandchildren taken
away so now it's my turn
and just lays out so what have we got
we've got Loris rot in a cell because of
you the high Sparrow rules the city
because of you our two ancient houses
face collapse because of you and your
stupidity which is like what people have
been saying yes is what we want to save
Cersei yeah and it's like I wonder if
you're the worst person I've ever met
and a certain age it's hard to recall
but the truly vile do stand out
throughout the years qml gar ash uh and
of course the the jab at the high
Sparrow i'm leaving this wretched City
as fast as I can before that shoeless
zealot throws me into one of his cells
the shoeless zealot that's the one
shoeless as ever what a phrase um and I
like that we've we've ranked these and
the ten out of ten that we have is
you've lost Cersei it's the only joy I
can find in all this misery so as usual
a secondary spoiler warning if you
didn't watch the next time on game of
thrones and you want to go into nick's
except so fresh turn away now but for
everyone who wants to kind of understand
what's coming up in next week's episode
which is no one to keep watching alright
so it doesn't seem to be clicking ball
just yet but we do get a confrontation
between the faith and the crown so we
have Cersei and Al and sell step aside
or they'll be violence I choose violence
and then later on we have the mountain
ripping someone's head off he's gone
from crushing them to pulling off he's
mixing it up you gotta give him that he
likes a bit of varied what's his
obsession with heads is it becoming
because his ones messica he's just
trying to gain you head we also see
Breanna pod in the Riverlands this is
what I think is gonna be a great plot
point because they spent so long
establishing the relationship between
Briana and jaime and brienne loves you
dare to talk to the blackfish and get
them on side but she's like Oh Jamie
you're on the other side to me I'm are
we gonna have we have to check this out
Jamie would not win that fight yeah he's
only 100 and she's gentle and she is
savage she's amazing um what else have
you got then it's just Jamie talking
some
talking crap about how much he loved
Cersei I don't understand why he loves
her so much well no one else is gonna
love him anymore yes I screwed up enough
he's been banished but like she was
she's ruining everything for them mm-hmm
and she's like repeated failures now
she's very slowly failing at everything
she does surely Jamie should be at some
point me like you know you're not doing
20 I'm gonna I'm gonna leave it's like
brother-sister love it's you know it's
real it's real but yes Gabriel is the
Freud kind uh so we also see the hound
swinging at someone so this is the
Brotherhood is it a tree a tree yeah
still chopping chopping some word um
we've got Braun grabbing well what we
assume is Braun hmm um grabbing pod
mm-hmm so I mean unless like if Brianna
and Jamie are fighting underlings have
to find something to do and that's
something like bronze using pod as a
poor yeah he's lightning trip yeah
breann you're gonna do my bidding
otherwise pop prods gonna get ya which
will be interesting considering there
there arc has been like they start off
not liking each other you know get we
get to see how much he actually cares
about pod after all this time will she
kind of try and get him back or we
should be like I don't really care about
him I never cared and do whatever no I
think I think air we also get to see
Tyrion looking at a lamp for the lights
itself second stall clappers yeah so I'm
gonna say red priestess here talking
about them i mean you're not dinero's
isn't back yet is she still with a
capital you know they're still trying to
figure out like what to do marine we
also have some like legit Assassin's
Creed stuff yeah so if you freeze frame
on this running segment that is
definitely the wave she's don't run some
track she's running after i er I appears
to just leap over like I hope it's a hay
bale yeah but like Eagle sound secure
ization point um so I think that's gonna
come to a head which is interesting that
because we were saying that like Ali's
definitely led her to a trap so if she's
running away wait running makes any
sense mm-hmm unless something goes wrong
yep um and then as we said we've got the
mountain riff in someone's head off I
can't wait see that yes so there's these
lies
three episodes are longer than the
previous episodes have been the process
has been like 53 minutes I think the
finale is gonna be like 70 80 odd
minutes which is featurelength
featurelength movie so guys what do you
make of this week's episode I I thought
is it was a bit weird mix like I really
like what they're doing they're setting
up a lot of interesting things but
unfortunately there's a lot of filler
and like boring stuff in between like we
had some good SAS which is great but
obviously the good thing was the best
part of it was the hound dog at the same
time it could have been completely like
it resolves itself within a single
episode which gives it very little
gravity like you see him he's back he
may change he's not going to change
anyway moving on so like that part of it
was kind of mmm but I'm just really glad
to see the hand back and also you know
bronze back which is always a good thing
yeah LeBron yeah aria is moving towards
full ninja mode which is exciting yeah
like you said like the two most
interesting parts for me was the Hound
revelation and I is lil Ark there yeah I
think everything surrounding that is
just they spent two or three episodes
sowing seeds to what's gonna come to the
rest of the season but I think what
they're doing is they've gone all this
other way and then the last three
episodes are just gonna be way intense
yeah especially as well I think the
yarra and Theon and De Niro spot line
hopefully will happen next episode of
the episode after because I want her off
that rock I want her over I want her
getting stuck in I want to finish her I
could get stuck in because she's got
some vengeance to do hmm but I guess
we'll find out next week we will we
should really exciting so if you want to
come find us on Twitter I'm at least
James games I'm at a regular Dave I'm an
actor more hitch if you want to listen
to the podcast version I search we
gamespot of Thrones on itunes and you
can listen to our lovely voices on your
commute which is always great I find yes
um so that's it we'll see you next week
thanks for watching
you
you